capitalism right now is going through a
reckoning
[Music]
there has to be a way in which profits
and planet align
esg in theory should help but that's not
what is happening today our sustainable
investments benefit you and parts of the
world that need it most
the whole business is built on the idea
that you can invest in companies
that will allow you to do well as an
investor but also can do some good for
the world perhaps the greatest
investment opportunity
in modern history
esg is now big business it represents by
some estimations something like 35
trillion dollars worth of investments
and in the last two years it's grown by
15 percent and that rate of growth
doesn't seem to be stopping
underneath this entire system are
ratings that look a lot like the credit
ratings of companies
but are based on completely unregulated
data and one company has come to
completely dominate that business and
and that's msci
so even though a lot of people are
talking about esg not many know what
goes into making an esg rating for
example and that rating is what
becomes the basis for decision making
for investors esg ratings focuses in on
what's significant to a company's bottom
line what we found is that the
foundation of this multi-trillion dollar
new cash machine for wall street is not
at all what it appears to be and then
it's really
almost exactly the opposite of of what
people think it is
[Music]
i'm cam simpson i'm the senior editor
and reporter for investigations at
businessweek in bloomberg
there are about 160 different companies
that sell data and ratings that report
to rate companies on their environmental
social and governance
practices or factors because it's a
completely unregulated business because
it's completely subjective the ratings
can land anywhere across the board
msci's rating system is built on scores
and they're converted into ratings that
look like credit ratings
aaa top of the line triple c bottom
by mimicking a credit rating which is
regulated which is based on regulated
data msci has created kind of an aura of
respectability an aura of confidence for
the investing world around these ratings
i'm akshat rathi and i'm a reporter with
bloomberg news i write about all things
climate
msci has been around for more than two
decades and it started its life as a
company that would arrange stocks in an
electronic index as the company
progressed it found this demand for
esg metrics that people were interested
in not just ensuring that they were
making profits from their portfolios but
that the companies within those
portfolios were also aligning with
society's goals and so about 15 years
ago msci acquired a number of companies
that gave it the ability to be able to
create esg ratings msci has become the
giant in the field
by one estimate 40 cents on every dollar
that is spent on esg ratings is earned
by msci so what msci does with its
ratings really matters to the entire
industry
so if you're a company especially a
bigger company that's included in the s
p 500 for example
your esg rating can really
significantly
help you in the world to get included in
one of these funds it can lower your
cost of capital which also can help you
and so they're really keen to have good
ratings and so when a company's rating
goes up msci produces an updated report
that shows what the key factors were
that led to the company
moving up the asg ratings ladder moving
up its score moving up its rating and so
i started just with that with a list of
companies and upgrades and to see how
quickly and how high some of them could
climb
we found half of the companies out of
the 155 that we looked at got upgraded
just for sitting still
because msci changed the way it weighted
the score or changed the methodology so
their scores went up as a result take
mcdonald's for example its total
emissions are those that match the
entire country of portugal or hungary
and
much of those emissions come from its
use of beef but when msci gave it an esg
rating upgrade in april 2021 it did that
by
reducing the weighting of emissions from
a mere five percent to nothing
and instead replacing it with a new
initiative that mcdonald's had launched
around recycling
except that the recycling initiative
came from installing bins in select
locations in the uk and france
and when we looked at that we found that
within uk and france there was either an
upcoming regulation or a threat of a
regulation which would have forced fast
food companies like mcdonald's and
others to anyway install these recycling
bins
and so
mcdonald's essentially got a ratings
upgrade for doing the bare minimum that
it should have done anyway and for not
being counted for all the emissions it
was putting out into the atmosphere
[Music]
and mcdonald's is not a singular example
it's actually quite typical when we look
at the 150 upgrades nearly half of the
companies
got that upgrade in their esg rating
without even fully disclosing their
emissions
we found the factors that were driving
upgrades over and over again were for
things like what msci calls corporate
behavior the other one that also was
kind of surprising was data protection
and also the structure of boards deemed
to be a factor in potentially having
better outcomes for shareholders of the
155 rating upgrades that we looked at we
found only one
where a reduction in carbon emissions
was cited as a significant factor in the
upgrade the rating system and the
ratings themselves
create exactly the opposite of what many
investors believe they're looking at
when they see a highly rated company
they think that company has strong
environmental social and governance
practices in terms of its impact on the
world its sustainability but what
they're actually measuring is exactly
the opposite is the company sustainable
is the value to shareholders sustainable
what's the impact of the world climate
change water shortages potentially on
the company it was a hard thing to get
our heads around until we saw it all
together
in the data msci is the leading provider
of investment tools in the world
and as such in our basic raw material
are sophisticated models
big data
and advanced technology henry fernandez
is the ceo and chairman of msci and has
been since the founding of the company
and we met henry at cop 26 where
governments meet but increasingly
businesses have been playing a role in
shaping the conversation around
climate change and how much they are
doing to help fight climate change
we asked him
do you think ordinary investors retail
investors have any idea that the entire
lens of the system is the impact of the
world on the company and not the impact
of the company on the world and he said
no they didn't have any idea and in fact
he said he thought even investment
managers who were putting together these
funds didn't grasp it you know they're
not really concerned about the impact on
the world the investment managers their
fiduciaries and
their interest is in their fees he said
he's a libertarian and that he would
like as little government intervention
as possible and wanted to ensure that
the use of esg would be one way in which
he can stop any socialist ideas from
creeping into capitalism
at any cost this is a permanent change
in the way capitalism works and by the
way we're doing this to protect
capitalism otherwise government
intervention is going to come socialist
ideas are going to come and the like so
it's not against capitalism it's about
you know dealing with the externalities
that are created in capitalism henry
fernandez was born into
an incredibly privileged family in latin
america henry wound up at stanford where
he decided to get an mba that was really
kind of
at the height of the greed is good
movement on wall street and henry then
decided that he would go into finance he
ultimately found himself at morgan
stanley and morgan stadley had a
partnership with a company called the
capital group capital group
international
by the start of 2019 it was clear that
this
massive shift
driven significantly by millennials
and their pension funds
was
really going to take hold and that
created demand
for investment managers all over the
world to sell investments to the public
that purported
to make the world a better place so
henry fernandez took his bland kind of
back office wall street company and he
rebranded it and he's done pretty well
from it since your company has had an
amazing run since it was spun off from
morgan stanley what'd you say up ten
times since
or that we went public at 18 a share 12
years ago and it's 220 today
henry appears to be the first esg
investing billionaire his shares are now
worth about 1.3 billion dollars which
makes him
almost as wealthy as tim cook the ceo of
apple companies have a hard time often
time getting their founders getting
their directors getting their executives
to invest in their businesses henry has
his whole net worth and his business and
basically his board actually said to him
we'd like you to sell a little bit of
stock henry and henry said i'm not going
to sell stock i think i'm going to make
three or four times my money in the next
10 years why should i sell any stock esg
ratings have come under the scanner in
recent years and so in this wild west of
esg ratings regulators now are honing in
on figuring out a way in which they can
standardize how esg ratings are made and
make sure that esg ratings don't end up
green washing a company's activities
the securities and exchange commission
has come up with a regulatory agenda to
bring in more regulation as far as esg
disclosures are concerned it'll be
critical i think in the next several
months to see what the securities and
exchange commission does and whether or
not they're going to crack down on some
of the claims that are really critical
to bolstering esg investing versus what
esg investing really is society hasn't
changed you know you would have been
intolerant of a transgression 100 years
ago except that you didn't know it it
was not prevalent now today you can find
out very quickly if somebody is doing
something wrong and therefore society's
tolerance towards that is very limited
there's no question that shareholder
action can move companies can move
companies away from
uh things that are you know really
really driving climate change or other
ills in the world
but those moments are incredibly rare
and the idea that these funds investing
in these funds is doing anything to make
the world better
it's really really hard to see how
that's the case
and there is a huge demand from people
especially young people around the world
to not have their pensions and their
investments destroy the planet that they
live on whether it will be met with
anything that's real is uh is a really
hard to answer questions
[Music]
you